negotiating with terrorists that's the
focus of tonight's
Angle now we all know it's been a
long-standing US policy that our
government does not negotiate with
terrorists who are making threats or
taking hostages now it makes sense right
as a general matter because saying
otherwise would put an invisible bounty
on the heads of Americans traveling or
working abroad and as years wore on US
presidents generally maintain this
policy but as usual Obama muddied the
water
all the while claiming to stick with the
old policy I firmly believe that the
United States government paying Ransom
to
terrorists risks endangering more
Americans and funding the very terrorism
that we're trying to stop at the same
time we are clarifying that our policy
does not prevent communication with
hostage takers by our government the
families of hostages or third parties
who help these
families and when appropriate our
government May May assist these families
and private efforts in those
Communications now obviously we all
understand and or try to understand the
pain that families of these hostages are
going through and its desperation But
ultimately Obama's move did nothing to
disincentivize hostage takers if
anything it did the opposite and don't
forget this move came after Obama's
absurd swap of five high-ranking Taliban
prisoners at gitmo for one US Army
deserter Bo bergdall
we had the cooperation of the
qataris uh to execute an exchange and we
seized that opportunity in terms of uh
potential threats the release of the uh
the Taliban who were being held in
Guantanamo uh was conditioned on the
qataris keeping eyes on them and
creating a structure in which we can
monitor their activities we will be keep
keeping eyes on them oh yeah we all know
how that ended up one of the released
prisoners is suspected of returning to
the battlefield the qataris were really
on it though and now a more dangerous
precedent could be set with more than
200 hostages including at least 10
Americans that were taken by Hamas
during the October 7th attacks now
rather than being held accountable and
quickly for their barbaric murder of
civilians and the torture of women and
children Hamas is using hostages to win
propaganda points and stallin Invasion a
quick warning you know it is Hamas video
at the start of this piece and so it's
not clear what propaganda purpose they
may have been thinking of when they
allowed this to be
filmed this is the extraordinary moment
an 85-year-old Israeli grandmother was
released by herass it's okay let's go in
video recorded by the militant group you
can see her shaking the hand of a massed
gunman Shalom or peace she says as she's
LED away now the report did go on to
discuss the ordeal and describe the
atrocities committed against the kotes
but still Hamas got a very valuable
photo op with that
handshake now of course we all want the
hostages to be released and safely but
we also risk losing sight of what
they've done to innocent Israelis by
parting lines about the terror group's
wartime
preparedness we these tunnels have
ventilation we know that they've been
known to have air conditioning there was
shampoo there was antibiotics there were
Medics and paramedics it is pretty
stunning because you got to contrast
that with what's happening above the
ground right where there isn't water
never mind shampoo okay but Hamas had
stockpiled all of that and has all of
that underground well that's true but
that's not all Hamas didn't simply have
AC and meds they were prepared for
female hostages everyone was surprised
by the scale of the actual terror attack
itself but the preparations for hostage
taking also seem to be a significant
piece of the
plan yes when they say prepared for
thing women's needs okay they were
therefore
prepared I mean let's just just go ahead
I think we've been honest about that
means they had tampons and things okay
that is a level of preparation for what
they were going to do now if I didn't no
better I'd say that CNN unwittingly
There is almost giving Hamas a five-star
rating on trip advisor in the mundane
reality of having feminine hygiene
products shampoo and antibiotics uh it
is those very specifics I think that are
most
striking no what's most striking is how
little we seem to have learned about
Terror groups taking hostages if you
give them an inch they will take a mile
and next time they're going to take more
prisoners this is why I think we should
just let Israel make its own decisions
here because when the Biden people get
involved nine out of 10 times it's a bad
outcome now remember this is the same
crowd in the Biden White House that
transferred $6 billion to Kadar to fund
the release of Americans and Iran only
for humanitarian needs that six billion
is going to be used for now Under
Pressure post October 7th the White
House did order the funds to be put on
hold but not permanently Frozen about
the $6 billion I understand Iran hasn't
accessed to any of this yet it's you
know intended for humanitarian purposes
but there have been reports of this
quiet agreement so yes or no if Iran
wanted to access this today could they
I'm not going to speculate one way or
another here about future transactions
what I can tell you is none of it has
been accessed and we are watching every
dime as you would expect we would we're
watching it very very
closely now this is not the time for
amateurs but unfortunately that's what
America has in charge at a time when
Americans are being asked to go further
into debt to support Biden's foreign
policy we need clarity now more than
ever and to that point point you can
understand how young people get fooled
when our own press refuses to describe
Hamas accurately check out the
associated press's topical Guide to the
Israeli Hamas conflict it notes that
bitterness and anger on both sides exist
but then it claims that the term
terrorism and terrorist have become
politicized therefore they're not using
those terms to describe specific
groups Chu up another victory for the
pro Hamas propagandists who seem to get
an assist from the White House Podium
yesterday what is his level of concern
right now about the potential rise of
anti-Semitism in light of everything
that's going on in Israel look um uh we
have not seen uh any credible uh threats
I know there's been always questions
about uh credible threats uh and so uh
just want to make sure that that's out
there but look uh Muslim and those
perceived uh to be Muslim have endured a
disproportionate uh number of hate
fueled attacks now those comments spark
shock and outrage in the American Jewish
community and Beyond which led to kjp is
doing a big 180 today when Jews are
targeted because of their beliefs or
their
identity when Israel is singled out
because of anti-jewish
hatred that is
anti-Semitism and that is
unacceptable there's no place for
anti-Semitism full stop period This is
is important to the president it's
important to me personally and to
everyone in the
administration full stop period this is
embarrassing but then again she's been
embarrassing from day one so why is
anyone surprised
here the hard reality is that as long as
Joe Biden is President America is going
to continue as a nation that just Corin
from crisis to crisis and all of our
adversaries know this so they're going
to use our missteps to advance their own
interests and of course along with it
their propaganda efforts without a
competent senior staff with Biden in
charge a staff that's chosen on
objective Merit not on the basis of
political symbolism or because you're a
first Israel should politely tell
Americans thanks but we got this the
Biden team came into office firmly
believing remember that the biggest
threat to America it was Americans who
didn't agree with them you know Maga
people that's why the most ruthless
person in the entire Administration is
Merrick Garland because he's the one
fighting us as far as all the others
they're so Hess they become Unwin dupes
for our enemies and that's the angle hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else